[Music]
his coronavirus the end of New York as
we know it that's exactly what Urbanists
joel kotkin argued in a recent piece for
tablet magazine this is happening at a
time when the demographics of cities
like New York LA Chicago San Francisco
are all going in the wrong direction
other words young people are leaving
population growth is very low
I think the fandom is just one more
factor with lockdowns and extreme social
distancing bringing urban life to a halt
and New York emerging as the epicenter
of the national crisis a debate among
urban studies scholars is breaking out
over what this will mean for the future
of American cities on one side our
density skeptics like Kotkin who
believes the pandemic will only
accelerate and already present decline
in urban living while pro density
Urbanists like University of Toronto
professor Richard Florida say that New
York will do what New York has always
done bounce back biggest mistake people
ever make is Counting New York if
there's one place in the world don't
count out ever
Thomas Campanella a Cornell professor
who Co edited a book called the
resilient city after 9/11 agrees with
Florida no we're not looking at the end
of New York by any means nor are we
looking at the end of cities were very
similar predictions were made in the
wake of 9/11 and there was dispersal
certainly the firms in lower Manhattan
to camp to the suburbs they went across
the river elsewhere but many of them
came back and New York boomed as it's
never done before in the book Campanella
and his co-editor document cities that
did and didn't bounce back from
catastrophe and find the disasters that
damaged critical infrastructure such as
the volcanic eruption that buried
Pompeii or make land literally
uninhabitable such as the nuclear
meltdown in Chernobyl are most likely to
do irreparable harm cities have
recovered from pandemics fairly quickly
including New York after the 1918
Spanish flu to suggest that this is
sterna mark the end of the cities it's
ridiculous actually it traffic's in a
long tradition of anti urbanist
posturing and predicting it goes all the
way back to the found
generation in this country Oh Thomas
Jefferson really launched them in his
notes on Virginia extremis compliment
about how the mobs of great cities at
just so much to a nation as sores on the
body politic and John Adams wrote in a
very similar pain about how the people
living in crowded places in a small land
area are prone to contagions of madness
and folly as he put it D densifying the
city that's not gonna happen
we still have London and Florence and
Venice and all these cities that
underwent terrible pandemic diseases
again and again and again the black
death was at once a generation
phenomenon I remember my grandmother
telling me how she as a little girl in
Coney Island remembered seeing the
hearses every day going down surf Avenue
during the 1918 pandemic we have gone
through these things obviously in the
past cities are not going anywhere
New York is not going anywhere but
kotkin argues that what's changed is
that ever improving communications
technology has made all kinds of remote
work possible people are moving to
generally speaking less expensive very
often smaller cities in terms of broad
historical trends urbanization has
increased over the past 200 years with
the percentage of world population
living in urban areas rising from 2
percent to 50 percent more recently mega
cities like New York have experienced
significantly slower growth than small
and mid-sized urban areas the total
world population of small urban areas
with populations less than 500,000
people is 3 times that of mega cities
with the median urban resident living in
an urban area with a population of
650,000 and according to the US Census
Bureau almost 92 percent of population
growth within metropolitan areas has
been in the suburbs and exurbs from 2010
to 2030 or for that period but Kotkin
says New York is an immune what the
pandemic may do it may just accelerate
some of this you know I think there's
going to be people who are going to have
that memory of god I was living in the
studio apartment in Manhattan when this
happened
I was essentially in lockdown you know
which felt like a prison cell
you know that's probably not going to
leave a great impression between 2005
and 2007 teen remote work increased by
about one hundred fifty nine percent
according to one study with about five
percent of Americans working from home
according to census data Kotkin predicts
remote working trends will continue to
push more and more Americans out of big
city centers again what makes a pandemic
important is that the demographic and
economic trends were already running in
the wrong direction like if you take a
look at business service and high-tech
employment New York LA Chicago you know
basically lagging way behind the rest of
the country finance jobs have been
leaving New York for the last 20 years
but Florida points out that venture
capital is still concentrated in the bay
area in New York he predicts that the
corona virus pandemic will lead to more
geographic concentration so at the same
time that you're having people leave San
Francisco share of the tech industry the
bay area is increasing New York Sheriff
finance industry is increasing LA is
still a center of moviemaking and the
creative industry broadly and so I think
with restrictions on air travel the the
fact that it's harder to drop in and out
of those places will cause a stop or
further concentration but Florida agrees
with Kotkin that the growth of remote
work will also continue to drive the
growth of smaller cities in the American
heartland he points to a Kaiser Family
Foundation project called Tulsa remote
which pays tech workers a ten thousand
dollar stipend to move to Tulsa and work
from home
they got tens of thousands of
applications from people from San
Francisco in New York in LA and when I
go to Tulsa the people I meet are people
from New York from Chicago from San
Francisco from LA and so I think there
is a possibility for some of the second
and third tier communities instead of
trying to build a mini Silicon Valley
but literally say we're going to be a
connected hub of remote workers to an
incumbent economic center and I think
that can work
despite is provocative headline Kotkin
isn't predicting New York's and demise
rather he foresees a continued hollowing
out of its middle class with you
your population growth coming from young
single workers immigrants and the
ultra-wealthy
it's probably at this stage almost
impossible to see a return of
middle-class families to cities not
necessarily because of housing stock or
even prices is the kind of governments
that are being elected that's something
that people almost completely ignored
when you have governments that basically
think that homeless people can pitch
tents anywhere they want that's okay
when they can shoot up in public and all
that governments that are many ways very
anti business it's gonna have an effect
and the problem is as the middle class
has declined in these cities the
politics have gotten crazier in crazy
here I am a person of the left but when
you look at the dialogue popping from
parts of the urban left you just say
it's beautiful it has nothing to do with
solving the problems of our cities so
that's where you could get a very broad
coalition if you're going to save the
cities you're gonna have to take some
pretty strong steps which I think the
current mayors are probably reluctant to
do the city has an enormous appeal but
it's going to have to deal with the
crime problem with the homeless problem
with the education problem or else what
it will do is it will move increasingly
to a great place to be if you're rich a
great place to be if you're single in
twenty five and crappy for everyone else
that doesn't work long-term for New York
there's gonna be a premium now on no
[ __ ] no ideology can you make my
city safe or suburbs safe and secure so
this he's gonna have time to really
think about how to become a more
affordable City a more holistic City a
better city to be a hundred percent
honest of any city in the world that you
could point to over the course of the
next two decades
New York has the brightest future it
still has the brightest future but it's
gonna have a tough period of short-term
medium-term adjustment to get there
you